but if you're gonna say we need to put
our eggs in two baskets instead of one
so that when a disaster hits one planet
everyone else can just watch it and
watch half their species die and somehow
be okay with that rather than prevent it
from happening in the first place if
you're okay with that then fine but i'm
saying fix the problems that you don't
even have the problem you're trying to
escape
neil degrasse tyson welcome to the show
god thank you thanks for having me
elon bought twitter neil should he be
spending his time and money taking
people to mars what's going on
yeah i've stopped
passing judgment on what billionaires do
with their money i mean think about it
he could just be
having a yacht contest for who has the
biggest yacht you know billionaires have
whatever are their habits and i don't
know that any of us would behave any
differently if we had billions of
dollars so i've just stopped commenting
on
what a billionaire
billionaires do do or should do with
their money what i can say
is
if a billionaire is going to do
something
it's kind of interesting that he
single-handedly brought electric cars
back into uh
he created a new expectation for the
automotive industry basically
single-handedly and he reinvented
commercial rocket launch
so he's doing that with his billions and
he has 44 billion left over and he wants
to own twitter which he likes
all right uh i don't see anything wrong
with that by the way
most things out there have ceos who you
don't know
and you don't even ask
we just happen to know who the new ceo
of twitter is about to be and so now
this becomes a point of conversation
why isn't anybody talking about the head
of any other organization or company or
or strategic
uh
platforms of communication so
i think the level of scrutiny
is is
unjustified given
how much scrutiny we could be giving to
so many other things but that being said
if he does what everyone fears
especially on the left that he reopens
the floodgates gives trump an account
again um
i think we need to perhaps look at it a
different way
free speech is a
what you want is
to not suppress the speech that you
don't like but amplify the speech that
you do
and let
that be the the arena
of contest
of ideas
because
if you suppress
ideas
those ideas will still always be there
and they'll run around saying i have
this idea but these folks don't want to
hear it that's very different
from you losing the idea game in an open
contest
and then you say well how come nobody's
listening to you yeah because they
turned me off
because they they shut off the the
channels where i was communicating
because they don't want to hear anything
that i have to say or because everything
i said is wrong
all right these are two different ways
emerging truths can win but you want it
to be the second way because then no one
has a platform left
if it's a platform that is either
regressive
um
puts us all at an existential risk or
whatever let it lose on its own terms
speaking of existential risks how good
do you think mars is as a backup to
humanity one of the problems what you
want to back up well the fact that we
only have one cradle at the moment right
if something goes wrong here if we're
all being slowly turned into paper clips
or grey goo or there's a bio weapon that
gets released or whatever
we don't have some air-gapped backup
but i assume your listeners know what
you mean when you save world getting
turned into paper clips yes they do
they do so they're ai fluent is that
correct ai fluent yeah that's all one
word as well ai fluent yes
yeah they are so they know nick bostrom
they know about existential risk
hypothesis yes so
so
um
yeah or an asteroid or a virus whatever
or anything yeah so so here's my
rebuttal to that and by the way this
rebuttal is
i don't know many people who have this
rebuttal so this may just be an outlier
in the examples you're collecting
but
right now antarctica
is wetter and balmier
than any place on mars yet i don't see
people lining up to build condominiums
there
all right it's a wholly inhospitable
place
right now it's used for some tourism but
mostly for scientific research
if you want to move to mars
and do it in a way that's not having you
confined to a habitat module you'll want
to terraform mars
and that's turning
mars into earth
and then ship a billion people there so
here's my thought
if you have the power of geo engineering
to turn mars into earth
then no matter what is about to happen
on earth no matter what did happen on
earth you have the power to turn earth
back into earth
and so i don't see mars as in realistic
backup plan
because whatever you have to do to mars
you could do to earth and then that's
your backup plan on earth would it be
more difficult to terraform mars than to
perhaps survive a huge asteroid impact
or to combat no no no no you deflect the
asteroid what dude we're talking about
if we can fly to mars and terraform it
like fly to mars ship a billion people
there i think we'll know how to deflect
an asteroid okay okay am i
am i on a limb there when i i don't
think that you are but my point is that
there may be some existential risks
which are so existential or so difficult
to overcome that the mars terraforming
could be easier than it would be that i
can think of at this moment but yes i
will allow that possibility but there is
none i can think of
okay so how about a killer virus that'll
take us off let's invent an antiviral
serum that'll take out antivirus all
right that's is that a stretch to
imagine
it's less of a stretch
than flying to mars terraforming it and
shipping a billion people there
fair enough no matter what you come up
with it's less of a stretch of my
imagination as a problem to solve
than terraforming mars and ship a
billion people there that's how big the
problem is to do it
yeah the mars problem is because we
don't know how to terraform yet
we don't know how to terraform i think
we could build a habitat module sure we
can figure that out
um
yeah but how many people are going to
live there and you have to bring
supplies they have to have supply ships
so but still to do that
there's a lot of science and technology
and time and money
just solve the problems here on earth
just solve them
so you're saying that elon buying
twitter actually is the best use of his
money rather than his attention rather
than going to mars
oh no no i'm not i i i will not judge
what people should or should not do with
their money
okay yeah so i will not say i'm glad he
did this or that what i will say
is and by the way 44 billion is a
is it
15 percent of his wealth
20 percent of his work he's raised it
from investors as well yeah yeah yeah so
so
um
and by the way that wealth it's not like
he doesn't have that money anymore it's
invested in a thing that has value so
it's not like you went to buy candy and
you ate the candy and you don't have the
money anymore so
so
i'm not going to sit here and pass
judgment on how billionaires spend their
money i'm just not going to do that
i can tell you he wants to terraform
mars
i don't have a problem with that but if
you're doing it because you think earth
needs a backup plan that's the wrong
reason that's that's kind of objectively
false
it's not let me say that differently
it's hard to defend it for that reason
you can defend it for other reasons it's
a cool thing to do the technology
demonstration sure
but if you're gonna say
we need to put our eggs in two baskets
instead of one
so that when a disaster hits one planet
everyone else can just watch it and
watch half their species die and somehow
be okay with that rather than prevent it
from happening in the first place if
you're okay with that then fine
but i'm saying
fix the problems that you don't even
have that solution you're trying to that
pro that problem you're trying to escape
have you looked into astropolitics much
who's going to own mars who owns
sections
of space that's that's so fascinating to
me you know is it first come first serve
is it another is it the new sort of
colonialist
uh era that we're going into now you
just get to stamp a little area out on
mars and it's yours yeah so
so
the only
successful if we can call it that model
that we have for this sort of thing is
homesteading
so if you
so let's say the international community
owns mars let's just make this up as you
know i'm pope of the un and i declare
that like antarctica
the international community has equal
access if you go there
and pitch tent and figure out a way to
make a buck let's say you have a mining
operations whatever then you get to keep
that land
provided the industry you create accrues
back to the rest of us in some way
or in some form
so
that has worked in the past
holding aside people taking land that
belonged to others
or you know and all the other
issues that
colonization brought with it the simple
fact of being the first on a plot of
land and doing something with it
getting to keep that land if you
manage to as they say develop it
that's a successful model in the past i
don't see why that wouldn't still be
invoked with regard to asteroids which
have basically unlimited natural
resources if you're the first on an
asteroid and you plant your flag you
keep the asteroid there's hundreds of
thousands of asteroids no shortage of
them to do this with by the way
one of them actually has my name on it
so if i were ever to travel to one i'd
probably put that one top on the list
which one
it's one three one two three tyson
why did you find it
no no uh that is one way to have an
asteroid named after you if you find it
i'm not an asteroid hunter but uh
there's some an asteroid hunter who is a
big fan of my work and respected what i
do and my efforts in the public so in my
honor they named it uh one one three one
two three is the numerical sequencing
and then the name is just tyson that
follows it that's pretty cool very
honored by that yeah that's very cool
what's your favorite answer to the fermi
paradox i spent an hour and a half last
night having a discussion with a bunch
of friends
yeah i think
um well
this is my favorite answer but i don't
think it's the most realistic one my
favorite answer is they've already
visited
and have judged that there's no sign of
intelligent life on earth
did they come
explanation
another interesting explanation is
that
whatever
is the urge
to colonize as many planets as you can
which is what the fermi paradox that's
the foundation of the fermi paradox
right you have a civilization and it
travels to nearby planets around other
stars
and and then they then travel to two
other planets and they travel to two so
there's a
quick doubling time
where
in where you can
populate the entire galaxy
in just a few hundred thousand years
and that's small
compared with the history of life on
earth
that's even small compared with the
anticipated life expectancy of mammal
species which last i checked it is up
around 3 million years
so
but there's an interesting self-limiting
fact
which i'm going with in my explanation
here
it's
whatever urge
it takes for you to
colonize a planet
if that is a genetic driver
in an entire wave of people
who are colonizing the galaxy
then at some point you're going to want
to colonize the same planet that i do
and you're not going to take no for an
answer
neither will i
that's what got me here to where i am
right now
so we will then fight
until one person wins and one person
loses and that will happen at every turn
when the number of planets that can be
colonized begins to drop relative to the
ones that have been and you'll get
infighting
and the entire system implodes
by the way that kind of already happened
in europe
portugal rises up
spain rises up france rises up
england rises up they have these
powerful navies and they want to
colonize the world and in the end what
do they end up doing fighting each other
over who owns what colony in the world
so
it could be that the very urge to do
that is self-limiting
the very urge
to populate every planet
is the very same force that would
prevent that from happening in the end
that's an interesting way to look at it
one thing i've always considered is that
i think it would be difficult for any
civilization to be more emotional than
we are if you were to tune the intensity
of our emotions up our reactivity our
anger our sadness our despondency
whatever if you were to tune that up by
another
15
i think coordination becomes so
difficult that you really maybe not 15
maybe 25 to sort of 30 i think it's so
difficult that you can't achieve
anything which is wild to think that
we're near to perhaps the limit on how
emotional a civilization could be and
still not be completely ineffective
except we have a very big range of
expressed emotion among us within the
species
so
i don't know that i could characterize
yes i agree we're an emotional species
i'm not denying that but the people who
make decisions who allocate monies
who fund research and discovery
uh i don't necessarily think
that emotions are as forceful as you are
implying because they have constraints
they have rules guidelines procedures
checks and balances right right and
things get debated and decisions get
made
all right we didn't discover the higgs
boson based on emotion
right um
the
uh what else we
i guess we can say we went to the moon
based on emotion because we were a
little spooked by the soviet union but
it took in the end of the day science
and technology to accomplish that
you can't wish stuff or pray stuff into
space
so
so i i like where you're going with that
but i don't think it applies entirely
with us well that's what we try to do
right that's the reasons we have rules
and procedures in place in an effort to
try and constrain some of those worse
aspects or else everybody would be
making decisions purely based on emotion
yeah that's correct yeah i agree with
that
do you think that we should be trying to
message
aliens there's metti as well as seti
right messaging extraterrestrial
intelligence and i know that it's quite
contested about whether that's a safe
thing to do or not well so once again
it's like the terraforming mars
it makes a good headline you know don't
tell the aliens we're here because
especially since we know in advance
without asking you
you are not going to give your email to
a stranger on the street
or your home address you're just not
going to do that
and this is another person who's our own
species
they're they're your species and you're
not giving them your return
now we're talking about giving our
return address to aliens out in the
galaxy
and
that's
so
whatever distrust you have of your
fellow species
you think that should be magnified
as a distrust of
um aliens so i get that and i don't have
a problem with that except
the aliens already know where we are
we have an 80-year radio bubble
of radio signals that came from tv sets
that came from broadcast antennas
and
this is 80 light year radius expanding
at one light year per year is a radius
of radio information about our species
and about our culture
so aliens can learn practically
everything they'd want to know
even if it's not everything they need to
know
in our television broadcast
shows
so
the honeymooners they learn how men
interact with women
um they might you know see
the flintstones and wonder what's going
on there
uh
so
so yeah
this to to be worried about a signal
being sent today when signals are being
sent inadvertently for the past 80 years
uh i think is is mis
misguided concern
because we've already let that horse
bolt out of the gate
correct
interesting yeah i am
i wonder i i'm really not not sort of
too convinced by the the concern about
messaging
you're right anyone any civilization
that we should be sufficiently scared of
because they're going to come and try
and destroy us has probably already been
able to detect that we're here and
it does seem a little bit like looking
at a teacup in uh out of an ocean and
going look well there's nothing in here
we know that there can't be anything out
there that's the equivalent temporally
with how long we've been around we've
been around what 50 000 years when we
could have actually written stuff down
and it might be on a cave somewhere or
whatever like
there's been a significantly longer
period of time that aliens could have
been and gone and decided that they're
not bothered with this planet
yeah and pluts if you're listening in
for radio signals
uh if they listened in 2000 years ago we
would have had the roman empire by
anyone's measure that's civilization or
the egyptian empire thousand years
whatever before that and but
if they don't have a radio signal to
send back you would think that there was
no intelligent life here on earth when
there clearly was
that's a good point technology and
civilization have a lagging a lagging
measure right talking about talking
about that bubble i've been thinking
about how
whether anybody has estimations about
how big the universe is outside of the
observable universe is there any way
that this can be
there's some estimates but there it's
like very
loose
estimates what do you even base it on
well you can look at
um
so
you can look at how big our universe is
and how long it's been expanding and ask
if you were randomly to come upon a
universe
what is the likelihood of coming upon it
within the first 14 billion years rather
than the whole rest of its life
and so you make some
uh some estimates along those lines and
then you can conclude
how much bigger
the full universe is relative to how
much time we've been expanding within it
and i free i don't remember the
estimates
it's i actually with the numbers in one
of my recent books it's in cosmic
queries we give the size that the
universe
could likely be beyond the visible
horizon i just don't remember exactly
what the number was
i learned about the buetta's supervoid
this week have you heard of that
tell me the name again
it's b.o
yeah it's got a whatever it's called not
an ampersand over the second oh that's
it
booty supervoid yes yes yeah it's a
constellation um and yeah it's just a
region of the universe where there's
hardly any galaxies like 300 million
light years across it's interesting yeah
it's 300 million light years across i
think yeah it's got it doesn't have
bright stuff in it it probably has
lighter smaller things that are less
visible
uh and
yeah that's kind of fun
the universe is not the universe is like
a sponge
where
if you take a cut through it you'll see
voids where there's no sponge and then
on the edges of the sponge
edges of the void you'll see the sponge
material and that's what the galaxies
look like
when you take slices through them in
space-time
it's interesting because
the universe is supposed to be
relatively homogeneous right isn't that
one of the things that well it was it's
statistically homogeneous
above a certain scale it's obviously not
homogeneous
in your the room that you're standing in
because you're in one place and there's
air in another place so if it was
homogeneous your molecules would be
equally spread
in the room that you're located so you
have to say on what scale is it
homogenous
and
if you back up enough and you see enough
contents you could say now
i have a certain mixture of galaxies in
this volume i look over here and i see
approximately the same mixture over here
and up there so then you know
what counts as the
um that
uh
you know it counts as the
um that is representative yeah of what
the universe looks like
the scale at which we can start to draw
some conclusions about what it's going
to be yeah it's i mean if it's not 300
million light years though you think
that that was what inferred to me oh
well maybe the observable universe is
only a really small part of a much
bigger universe because within this you
don't have a massive amount of
homogeneity
right
right so but a big enough volume you do
so that's how you get out of that just
scale out a little bit more right
correct
if the big bang was when time began
when's time going to stop
um so there's no
evidence that it would stop
well it would stop at the big rip um
for sure but if we don't have the big
rip where the universe is expanding so
fast
that it rips the very fabric
of the universe
um
that
if that does not happen then we'll just
expand forever and so time just
continues forever would the big freeze
not
eventually end up with everything
decaying on a long enough time scale to
the point where time kind of becomes
irrelevant
yeah oh no that's a different question
right so if i keep winding a watch the
watch will keep time but there's a point
where
what energy am i using to wind the watch
while i'm eating some food where that
gets indicated from the sun the sun is
gone then there's no energy and i can't
wind the watch and so
there is a limit
to this
and
the
but otherwise
the time just slows the the
there's nothing left for you to care
about timing
that's really how to think about it
there's nothing there you know how long
did you run that race there's nobody
running a race how long did you boil the
egg there are no eggs right so
uh there's a i guess we can call it a
practical end of time
when there's nothing left to measure
time with
but otherwise uh it would just continue
forever
yeah interesting
i learned as well the same day that i
learned about the buetta's super void uh
about
the reason or a question about why the
plank length
exists why is it that there's a smallest
measurement at all
is there a reason for that
um well so it depends what you mean by
reason why can't anything be smaller
than it
because that is the very structure
that comprises everything that's bigger
than it
so
now there's a
there's a movement
a cottage industry i should say
that
is wondering whether the plank length
this smallest unit
considered like a voxel a volume pixel
right this plank length is fundamental
or is there something more fundamental
than that there's emergent research to
suggest
that space and time
emerge
from other forces operating
and
uh that's that's an interesting
fact so if that's the case maybe you can
get something smaller than a plank
length but not by any known means
that gives us an understanding in the
first place
there's an equivalent in time as well
isn't there yes yeah so the the plank
length in time is how long it takes
light
to cross a plank length oh no way
yeah yeah so that's a so that's a unit
of time and that makes a cube
in space time
that is interesting the most the coolest
explanation that i heard for it was that
the plank length is the pixel size of
the simulation that we're living in
yeah that's another way to put it that's
right but when you get to the big rip
who knows what that will look like and
we have no idea
and by the way yeah if we are a
simulation and you want to think about
it that way there's nothing there's
nothing stopping you
from saying these are the pixels of our
simulation
is it right that the speed that light
goes at
is the maximum speed that anything can
go at is that determined by the fact
that it's light or is that a maximum
speed limit and it happens to be that
light travels at it
we don't know but both are true
both are true and by the way when light
slows down
like so does when it enters
transparent media that are more dense
than air
the
um
so when it slows down
it actually hasn't slowed down
it's moving at the speed of light
between the molecules but then it has to
pass through a molecule and that that
slows down the total the total
got to go a further distance as it
weaves through so i don't know if it's
quite just further distance
or
if it's
the interaction that it has with the
molecules of the substance
i wouldn't think it's a further distance
because
that would imply
something different spending
yeah yeah and i don't think it's
distance dependent but uh in any case
this this
uh so the speed light is still going at
the speed of light even when it's moving
slower that's my point
which makes complete sense obviously
right right right right uh yeah i just
found that really interesting you wonder
whether the
maximum speed that things can go at is
the speed of light or if there is a
maximum speed that things can go out and
light happens to travel at that speed i
thought that was an interesting
distinction
well except
material items can't travel at the speed
of light
so so
i'm recording
um
so you you you have my image here
and
if sorry if i wanted to then join you i
can't
i can travel 99.99
percent speed light but i can't travel
the speed of light
it's it's pretty it's forbidden
all the equations forbid it and we've
never seen it happen
yeah well i don't know i the
the insights around uh how
future civilizations can perhaps travel
whether or not we can worm a whole
tunnel our way across the galaxy and
stuff like that
that kind of goes back to what we were
talking about earlier on with
the intelligent life it's not a surprise
when you see just how spread out things
are you know it's only a presumption
based on how likely it is that
some life has occurred within our galaxy
but if the universe is as big as we
thought it is and we don't have another
example of life
evolving it's pretty difficult to work
out whether or not we should actually be
seeing aliens at all i can't remember
what the
uh
letter is in the fermi paradox um but
does one
what is it what's the typical equation
that goes along with the fermi paradox
no don't confuse it with the
the drink equation that's it thank you
right right oh you did okay
that's yeah we've got a drink equation
you start out with the total number of
stars in the galaxy you start hacking
away at it with fractions
what fraction of those stars have a
planet what fraction of the stars of the
planet have life what fraction stars no
what flexion of stars of planets are in
the goldilocks zone and what fraction of
those in the goldilocks zone have life
and what fraction of those in the
goliath zone was life have intelligent
life what fraction of those in the
goldilocks zone that have life and have
intelligent life have intelligent life
with technology that can actually
communicate
and that enables you to remove the roman
empire from this
because like i said they wouldn't have
known
how to answer back
if someone tried to talk to them
where is the biggest hole in the drake
equation for you or what's the biggest
question mark over
right now it's the for me it's what is
the anticipated length that a
civilization is capable of communicating
and
uh
that because that one
doesn't rely on pure astrophysics
there's a social cultural dimension to
that
and
i
i can't bring my methods and tools of
science to address that
is are we wise enough to be good
shepherds of the power that we wield
such that
seven generations from now they'll be
proud of us as their ancestors for
having preserved the earth
i don't know that
i ca
that's
that's how
that's how it should be
okay but it's not that of course outside
of your scope a little bit
right do you think that
our descendants will leave the milky way
eventually
no
you don't think so
no
nothing we can't there's just no reason
to
i think
as the sun gets hot and bulbous we might
want to move out to mars
and
that
will matter and
because mars is farther away so we get
to delay the inevitable demise
of our civilization
by knowing this well in advance
and
taking precautions to accommodate it
but
otherwise
you know i
you know i'm good with earth
just as we have it
that's got a limited time span on on it
though right what what what what what
are you timing out on us well whether it
be the sun boiling off
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so we have to
assume that we as a mammal species
outlive a typical mammal species that
goes three million years
we have to somehow
make it clear
that
we want to give we want to live beyond
earth itself and even beyond the sun
right so first you're gonna planet hop
your way away from the sun but then you
have to find another star
by the way something not talked about
when the sun exhausts this hydrogen in
its core
as a big ball of helium
the sun dies the sun will die because it
can't convert helium into carbon
okay that's fine
so
how about all the rest of the star
it turns out if you find a way to cycle
material from the outer star to the
inner star
if you can do that
then you will prolong the life of the
star met 10 to 100 times
because it only burns out when it's no
longer hydrogen in its core
but the fresh hydrogen in the rest of
the star and you constantly funnel it
down
uh you've got
you've got exactly what you need
was that was it sunshine was that the
film where they send a mission to drop i
think they drop a nuke actually into the
the heart of the star in an effort to
try and get it back but wait that was
the that was the science fiction movie
i'm aware i'm aware yes i'm getting i'm
i'm trying to bring this back to the
real world so
my point is just that that was talking
about somehow impacting the
natural flow of the sun and what you're
saying here is that if there was a way
to funnel that back in it wouldn't be a
nuke but if there was a way to do it
correct you just you just give it a new
lease on life in fact
there are these stars called blue
stragglers that's what we call them that
should have evolved
into a different state at the time we
noticed them but they haven't
and all evidence points that it's two
stars that have collided and have become
one star and the act of colliding
re-churned up the fuel supply and it has
given it a new lease in life so these
are stars that are lingering behind the
evolution of a of a star cluster
and we have no other explanation for
them but that their inners got churned
up
that's for new stragglers so we need to
find we need to find another star fire
it at r1 that would that would that
would be
short of reaching in with a ladle and
doing it ourselves like collisions
surely make that happen yes yeah like
you're cooking soup that would be one
solution
yeah it's um
one of the things i was thinking about i
think that a couple other guys at the
future of humanities institute are
looking at
solar forming so how you would if you
wanted to create a solar system and move
stuff out of the way that you didn't
need there um they're
talking about some of that at the moment
and i think that kind of probably ties
in at least a little bit with how you
would potentially be able to move a star
around or at least the material inside
of it
well so i'm not sure what their
objective is
we're in a solar system now that has
eight planets and they're not bothering
us i don't know why you'd want to move
it around
i can tell you that
modern
models of the formation of planets
show that
you can start a solar system with
upwards of 30 planets
and not all orbits will be stable
they
if they're not stable they'll fall into
the sun fall into jupiter or get ejected
from the solar system altogether
and so
uh
this is a
so maybe they're saying if you want to
hurry up the evolution of a solar system
you say okay let's get rid of these and
add those and subtract those to move
this into the right spot so that you
have the goldilocks effect
uh that
that's a that's not just geoengineering
that's star system engineering that
you know i don't see i don't foresee
that anytime soon is that the best way
if you wanted to design a solar system
to overshoot on the number of planets
that you would need and then sort of
allow the orbits to sort themselves out
well you don't need the extra planet so
just stick a nice size planet in the
goldilocks zone it's a one-planet solar
system it'll be stable
the instability comes when you have a
lot of objects tugging on each other for
every orbital period but you just throw
one and maybe throw in a saturn just to
be beautiful at night
just cool like like when you're
landscaping your garden it's got
something to do yes you know yeah i i i
understand yeah i mean
to see a
single planet
solar system would be pretty
cool
yeah and then you could say the sun is
all ours
even you mars with no one on it but
isn't it that most solar systems or the
vast majority of suns are
twin suns rather than yeah so i think
that the proper way to say that is more
than half the stars in the night sky
when investigated more closely reveal
that they're in pairs triples or just
multiple stars in a system
right so the single star
star system is is not as common as you
might think why do you think that is
just the way that gravity works no no
just planets go unstable
it's just
oh sorry sorry um
sorry
so
i mixed two answers
if you have multiple star systems you
don't expect them to have many planets
because planets will not fully track
their gravitational allegiance and they
can get ejected very easily oh it's a
less stable gravitational environment
stable and in fact
in the famous star wars scene where luke
is using on the sand planet and he comes
out and he looks there's a double sunset
all right very important and poignant
moment in the film containing the only
accurate astrophysics in the film by the
way so that's a planet orbiting a double
star system we've always known that
could happen they showed it but they did
it right because it is possible to orbit
two and multiple planets if your orbit
is far away compared to the distance
among the stars to each other
then the orbit thinks it's just one
source of gravity
but if the stars themselves are orbiting
at great distances from each other and
you are now weaving in and out and among
them that's a recipe for disaster
welcome to the universe in 3d which is
the new book that you've got out what's
going on with that what's what was the
the inspiration behind that oh yeah so
that's actually the fourth in a series
of welcome to the universe books uh the
first was
a textbook basically that i co-wrote
with two colleagues of mine when we
co-taught a class for introductory
astrophysics class at princeton
university the class went from like 40
people to 300
and so it was very popular very quickly
we had to change rooms twice
and
we were delighted by that but we think
we know why it was popular it was taught
in a very breezy way
very anecdotally
and all the three of us were pretty well
connected to all manner of things and so
it was it was just so in that sense it
doesn't smell like a textbook even
though it looks like one and but some
people said we want to use it as a
textbook for our class so we said okay
cool so then we wrote a problem book to
go with it because that enables you to
assign problems then people said this
book is too big i want to learn what's
in it but in a short format so then we
created welcome to the universe the
pocket size tour that literally fits in
your pocket and then we said the
universe is something to look at
and to embrace
so if we take selected hand-picked
images double them up in a stereo book
and you have a viewer then these images
become worlds they become real
they become something you would
interact with emotionally not just
intellectually so that's what that's
what welcome to the universe in 3ds is
66 images and it's a uniquely designed
a jacket binding so that the it unfolds
and you have the built-in viewer
but
the
um
uh it doesn't end there there's a
website welcome to the universe.net
where all four books are featured but
you go to the 3d book and as a bonus
feature
i've narrated the captions to each
image pair
and i
i use my planetarium voice
yes
welcome to the universe all right so
yeah i'm a direct planetarium director
so i got to have that voice right so
so that way you can participate in the
book while you're being read the
captions rather than move back and forth
and read them so this is a little little
uh after hours bonus that just
in the f it was like
ten days before the book releases that
why don't we do this
okay yeah but i'm the one that has to do
it
everybody
out voted yeah
so i ended up doing it so neil degrasse
tyson ladies and gentlemen what have you
got coming up next is there anything
that people should keep their eyes out
for
oh thanks for asking
uh i just finished another book it was a
coveted book
i said you know i could binge
more you know rick and morty or i can
write a book okay so i chose to
write a book
on a book that was
within me
it's a book i could not have written
even five years ago
and it's called
starry messenger
cosmic perspectives
on
civilization
and it is
me taking a look at all that
divide us
all that divides us and saying here's
what that looks like
from space
or here's how an alien would think about
it or here's what that
that argument you've just made here's
what that looks like when you add a
little bit of science to it right
science literacy and what you'll find is
that in most cases
the depth of your argument just
dissolves away
and you end up and i'm not talking about
a compromised position in the middle i'm
talking about a whole new place that
neither of you saw because you're not
thinking about it scientifically or
cosmically
and so there are chapters there's a
chapter in there on gender and identity
on color and race on truth and beauty
on life and death
on
on
meatarians and vegetarians there's
there's all
eternal conflict for you
and
uh there's risk and reward these things
that have child that prevent us from all
holding hands and singing kumbaya
that might still be possible
if you take another look at your
argument and that's what this book does
why couldn't you have written it five
years ago i wasn't wise enough i didn't
have enough
because it's it's not just let me throw
down some science i could do that at any
time it's
here's a nuanced way the science
influences this subtle argument you
think you're making that you think as
the end-all argument i've had i needed
enough exposure to that
enough encounters with people to hear
how they think about problems
so that when i come back at them i can
maximize the bandwidth of how i
communicate with them
so yes it's a book of maturity dare i
say when are you planning to get that up
oh it's already it's in press right now
so september
which is not even that far from that
like may june july august you know it's
four four and a half months
um and so
it'll be it'll have it's
by the way it's you can pre-order it i
think on amazon right now actually but
it's a it's a crazy
it's
i i would i would have been
irresponsible
given what i know about this world and
about science and about the universe
if i did not
offer this book
to the public i'd be irresponsible
and
uh you know they're little things
observations for example uh you didn't
ask but i'll just tell you um in the
risk and reward chapter it's all about
how ill-equipped we are to evaluate
probability and statistics
we are so bad at probability and
statistics entire industries exist to
exploit how bad we are
they call casinos they're called
lotteries okay
if we taught probability and statistics
in school
early in school
with same ranking as reading writing and
arithmetic okay reading arithmetic and
probability okay it's statistics add it
to that list if we did that
no one would play the lottery oh here's
something interesting in order to make
you always allow the lottery they use
lottery revenue to pay for education
so
if that money that went to education
went to teaching people probability
statistics
you couldn't hold the lottery because
all that extra education money would go
away right because no one would play the
lottery that's feeding you so it is in
the lottery's interest to not teach you
probability and statistics there's
interesting little
facts about this that run throughout
society and all those topics that i
mentioned
there's a whole discussion in there on
the removal of statues
you know uh have you thought about that
scientifically what that means what are
the arguments what is the weight of the
argument or are you reacting sort of
emotionally to it i don't mind emotions
but
emotion without some kind of foundation
in
in rational thought
um then society becomes a free-for-all
and there's no objective foundation on
which to base anything
not the least of which are laws
which should be based on objective
truths oh by the way there's an entire
section there on law and order
okay
and what does it mean
that a jury has arrived at a verdict
based on what
on a testimony
is that testimony from a human being
that use their own senses to evaluate
what is and is not true about this world
really you're gonna put someone in
prison based on a human being's
testimony
holy [ __ ] okay
you know in science if you came to the
to a conference this is true because i
saw it let's get the hell out of here
okay
our brain only barely works as an organ
okay
barely works
you can look at at
one of those books with the with the
images that fool you um optical
illusions go pick up any optical
illusion but there's a line
and and is is the line longer or shorter
than the other line i don't know
is the is it a vase or is it a face in
the these are simple line drawings that
completely confound us
and we're going to send people to hang
or however they kill them in
15 states because you have a testimony
that implicates them
oh my gosh so i'm bringing scientific
rationality to these issues
that's all it is that's that book is
about and it's a whole other thing
unlike anything i've ever written i
birthed the book during covet because
i'm alone and it was gurgling up in me
and the baby had to get born and it got
born and that's what happened and now
you're stepping into the culture wars
well except i'm not telling you how to
how to think or feel
i'm arming you to become a better
thinker
when it's time for you to feel about
what it is you want to pass judgment on
and what's that book called again
starry messenger cosmic
perspectives on civilization
neil degrasse tyson ladies and gentlemen
neil i appreciate you thanks
thanks for having me thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you